لم يبقى شيء كما كان قبل فجر الاثنين
هكذا كانت مدينه غازي عنتاب
هكذا اصبحت بعد دقائق فقط من الزلزال
هكذا كانت انطاكيا
هكذا اصبحت تغير شكل الحياه كثر فيها
الموت والدمار وخيام المشردين هذا ما فعله
زلزال كهرمان مراش وهزاته الارتداديه قبل
ان تشرق شمس السادس من فبراير
الصور التي تقارن حجم الدمار تعكسها
الارقام امتد زلزال في جنوبي تركيا
وشماليه سوريا الى مساحه اقتربت من مئه
الف كيلو متر مربع تلك مساحه تجاوزت
مساحات الدول في العالم هولندا البرتغال
النمسا سويسرا كل هذه الدول مساحاتها اقل
من المساحه التي ضربها الزلزال الاخير لا
احصائيات نهائيه حتى الان عن البنايات
المنهاره لكنها بالالاف او حجم الدمار في
البنيه التحتيه ولا حتى حصيله نهائيه لعدد
القتلى والجرحى والمشردين لكن اعداد
الضحايا الاحياء والاموات يتجاوز سته
وعشرين مليون انسان وهؤلاء كذلك يتجاوزون
عدد سكان كثير من الدول المنطقه المنكوبه
في تركيا تساهم باكثر من تسعه في المئه
بالمعدل من الناتج المحلي التركي بالاضافه
الى المساهمه بقرابه تسعه في المئه من
اجمالي صادرات التركيه تلك ارقام تعادل 76
مليار دولار امريكي هذا رقم يتجاوز
ميزانيات الدول كثيره كذلك هكذا مر
الزلزال على تركيا في الجانب السوري لا
ارقى مواضحه او تفاصيل الاكيد ان الزلزال
دمر في دقائق ما بني في عقود وانهى في تلك
الدقائق كذلك ما لا يمكن اعاده بنائه في
سنوات وبعض الخسائر لا يمكن ان تعود الى
الابد